I guess we just found that patently ridiculous.
Well,
we use,
we like,
um,
you know,
we,
we grew up,
I grew up hearing the word a lot from my,
my dad.
What does your dad like?
He's not like much anymore.
He's dead.
Thanks.
[inaudible] he died in [inaudible] 79,
sorry.
1979.
Okay.
Um,
but,
uh,
no,
as I always say,
he was mad.
There are no better parents than dead.
Parents know they can fuck you up.
What's right.
But my dad was a real,
really fond of that word and the English full Canadian,
you full Canadian.
But being Canadian is kind of like being English,
a little bit of English people in your money's still.
Yes.
And we get all the English movies on English,
TV show.
We,
we,
uh,
pledge allegiance to the Queen in school.
You know,
still it's still going on possibly.
Yeah.
And in our sleep,
so many good things about Canada,
yet so many preposterous things.
True.
It's the fact,
well,
the fact that a monarchy still exists at all is preposterous.
Is Great on paper.
Yeah.
Well,
the monarchy even itself has become Kardashian.
Refied well,
yeah.
Right.
But didn't they,
weren't they always,
I guess they were prince died days and,
yeah.
Or even just back to Henry the eighth I'm sure.
What,
what maintained the,
the monarchy other than the fact that people wanted celebrities and that was the
only celebrities they had.
Right.
And the priests and I think Henry the eighth also had asked implants if I'm,
he did.
Yeah.
Wow.
Good for him.
Progressive.
Yep.
So ahead of his time.
Yeah.
That is an interesting thing.
It's like the Prince Charles Lady,
Di's saga was essentially one of our first reality things to enjoy.
Yeah.
Yes.
That was madness when it happened.
It was so huge.
And then someone said,
well what if we just make housewives in orange county royalty and a,
and you don't have to pay them as much as the king and Queen and you can cancel
them.
Yeah.
Those shows are wonderful through,
I've never seen an episode of any of their fascinating,
the Beverly Hills one is,
there was,
well there's different versions of them,
right?
In different versions.
You get to see the geographical creepiness of like Atlanta does its own thing.
Yeah.
Atlanta's not a bad one.
The worst one was Jersey there.
They're fucking savage people.
Yeah.
That's my ancestors.
Those fucking savage monkey folk that live in the worst.
Anything Jersey version,
the worst of anything.
The worst.
The worst penicillin is the Jersey penicillin.
You know,
CSI Jersey was terrible by the way.
Now that doesn't exist.
Yeah.
Um,
the Beverly Hills,
one of the,
all of them were fascinating.
You'll take,
take people,
forced them in these situations where they're going to have his artificial
disputes.
Well,
it was crazy to me is watching people succumb to the pressure of all of that
attention.
Would it leave never experienced before and then you're gonna just thrust them
into this massively popular,
you know,
for lack of a better word,
confessed.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
if you take your tests yet,
I need divorce it up.
Any supporting,
sort of supporting under,
you know,
solid structure.
Yeah.
Island or that support [inaudible] offer.
Nothing to offer.
No offering.
There's no painting,
no sculptor.
He's still singing.
They only take,
yes.
Give cause fame will destroy if you're a brilliant artists,
fame will destroy you.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Fifth.
There's nothing underneath the fame.
It's just there's nothing to hold it up.
While I remember watching Kelsey Grammer's wife,
I had met her before,
she seemed like a very nice lady,
Camille,
Camille.
And then she,
uh,
I forgot her name.
Thank you.
With that,
I didn't want to just say I want to contact owner.
He is a huge Camille thing.
Giant.
I,
I have a tattoo.
I was gonna say,
do you have a tattoo?
But she decided to play the heel and a,
the,
it was so obvious at the pressure was just overwhelming.
The hatred that was coming her way.
She had decided she was going to be the boss bitch on the show and just let
everybody know,
you know,
this is how it is and I'm,
I'm here to run things and just swamp of evil.
That came her way and then she's like,
God,
quit done.
Fuck this show.
She bailed out of it.
Good for her.
Yeah.
Well,
it's even caused that role or double or was it like a producer and said,
here's your,
well according to Kelsey he told her like,
Hey,
okay,
this is what you've always wanted here.
Like cause that's like what led to their divorce or what was happening during
them getting divorced.
You know,
he essentially said,
you know,
this is what you've always wanted.
Like I don't think you understand this.
So good luck.
Good luck with it.
And then you know,
she,
she just kind of vanished afterwards.
Like fuck all this.
Which is why it's on her part.
She,
she,
she recognized what it is.
But they're like those,
those people that are on it.
Like I know some people who know some folks that are on that show and it's,
they just go crazy.
They started popping pills and losing their mind.
They're in therapy every day and it's just madness.
Yeah.
That desire for fame with nothing more to it than other than a desire to be
famous can only drive you insane.
Yeah.
Cause I think fame,
fame as a,
as an emergent property of doing something right is bearable.
True.
But it's fine products,
but so strange and so difficult to truly manage.
But you can at least say,
I don't define myself by the fame.
I defined myself by the work that created the thing.
Yes,
yes.
Whereas if there's no work underneath it,
it's you know,
you only exist in so much as people are aware of you.
You exist in those moments when you walk into a room and everyone's staring at
you.
That's what you look for.
And that's that.
I have that anyway because of my body.
So I guess I know real famous.
Yeah.
And your and the horrible allergy have to pay.
That's true.
I can't wear pants and yeah,
every time I walk into a room,
why I say like that,
that uh,
that fame is a property of the beholder,
not the beheld.
And that that fame only exists so long as somebody in the room knows who you
are.
And the minute you're in a room where no one knows you,
your fame evaporates.
That is one of the weirdest interrogations I've ever gotten is when people go,
Woo,
why did these people know you?
What do you do?
Who are you?
Who are you should I know I take a photo with you,
the where somebody,
but I don't know who the weird thing is,
they're almost defended that other people know you and they dumped.
Yeah.
Like why you're playing a game with me.
Why?
Why don't I know you?
They get angry.
Yeah.
Well that also,
there's the other thing about famous that people feel like they could just start
talking to you.
Yes.
Yeah.
They can sit next to you.
I know that.
Oh yeah.
You could be in the middle of an intense conversation with the,
your favorite person on the planet.
They don't give a fuck now.
Why hadn't I didn't know you that you've been in their house.
I had a living room.
I had a guy come to me in the street and just go,
Hey Dave,
how you doing?
And I thought,
oh,
I must know him.
So I said,
oh,
I'm good.
How are you doing man?
And his next line was a,
you don't even know me.
A fucking phony,
David.
That was me.
That was you.
I wish I was better at faces.
Was this in Canada?
This was in downtown La real.
It's amazing.
I don't even know me.
You fucking funny.
I'm just trying to be nice,
sir.
Yes.
Was he a drunk?
No,
it was just a,
he was the guy who just,
uh,
okay.
I'm going to go pretend I know them.
Just watch this.
Wow.
Was that the end of the conversation?
That was basically it.
Wow.
What a rude person.
That's terrible conversation guy who auditioned for news radio in 96 I've just
never gotten over it.
Yeah.
That fucking cunt.
Fuck.
Yeah,
that one.
I was on my way to start him.
Yeah,
and to be fair,
it was me.
Tripped him up.